okay
we're about to find out wowzer versus
natural legion's been doing a lot of
work but we've been seeing a lot of
elisa let's see who this goes to
this is
naturals only got six wins on that
account there's if you've been playing
gin i don't even know at this point i
don't know what to believe man
that's only ranked matches though right
that's those are only the ones
gets the back to one and still got the
tail spinning instantly goes back to the
wall
damn a lot of back and forth getting
finally is here
let's see if we can carry him to the
next wall oh yeah does this
a little bit late on the response
oh oh damn yo what's up i'll counter
where it goes for the charge
oh you should have did something bigger
like a can kicks and it actually to the
low the five points all right you know
who cares
you know he dropped off he just wanted
to
explain
for the family
for the fans you're all alive now
you got to believe that's why you need
two cans bro you got to be a good
neighbor bring one for you and one for
them
oh while staying stuck
[Music]
now two round lead
and this is actually a back to our first
or two match yeah just for the those
watching yeah yeah
your natural bounce wait a minute not
done yet yo the triple chain song
you saw the four four threes from
natural really do a lot in earlier games
gets the hell sweet this time
and hit you with a back two one just to
let you know it ain't even over yet
that's pretty crazy he really don't like
had deep control of that whole match
just he's dominating dude he's doing
good
i like it i like it
i shouldn't have cursed wowzer by saying
that it was my pick oh damn yeah see now
look at you crazy man yeah
i'm on there
it happens to look it happens now this
is when we get the true the true petro
rose feelings now you're like you know
what
that was a guy never liked this alisa
anyway hold on man
yo it's 50 50. it's actually 50 50.
really it's about 61 000 61 000 channel
points on wowzer it's 61 000.9
wow on natural it's 16 000.7
so you guys are pretty down the line
right now right down the middle for who
you believe is going to take to sit here
man once again just for you guys this is
the tekken online challenge oceania is
on the map we got two players here that
have clawed their way clawed their way
through this tournament still alive
trying to make it to losers final and
this is a best of three so if you trying
to stay alive you gotta win i don't know
who's going to win it though man wowser
or natural
infinite stage good choice
let's see
damn just responding directly
yo natural with the seven wins we've
seen this gin a couple of times in a
turn
oh yeah
damn he's got his mid pressure on point
right now
oh wow nice dark with that stand that
launch
hey that was calculated
let's go sleep
oh nice get the hard spike
with that while standing once yeah
damn
dude naturals killing it
two rounds away
wow they both went yo that's sad
why exclusive hook fists right there
oh double whiff
four four four another nice kind counter
here
damn there it is nice side stepping to
hop kick
let's see he has to get a lot of damage
out of this he can't skim on this it
resets on his scaling getting some sick
damage getting whiffed on and load it
damn taking that round
match point right now for natural
wowza really needs to kick it into gear
it needs to give you a three-round
turnaround
this is oh
whoa
big slide
i skipped him in check
damn don't get near me son
away from me
damn
just let you know man don't get in my
way bro
who's next hit him without you wrap it
up who's next
yo extra man that's who's next
extra miss now gonna be reversing
natural
um